defining your circle of competence is  the most important aspect of investing  it's not how important how large your  circle is you don't have to be an expert  on everything  but knowing where the perimeter of that  circle of what you know and what you  don't know is and staying inside of it  is all important  tom watson senior who started ibm  said in his book he said  i'm no genius he said but i'm smart in  spots and i stay around those spots and  you know that is the key uh so if i  understand a few things and i stick in  that arena  i'll do okay  and if i don't understand something but  i get all excited about it because my  neighbors are talking about stocks are  going up and everything  they start fooling around someplace else  eventually i'll get cream and i should